-Last time you were here
on the show,
we played charades and we won
'cause we were a great team.
-We really won. We kicked ass.
-Yes.
I thought maybe really quickly
if you don't mind,
I'd love to play
a new game with you.
-I would love to play a game.
-All right, this one is called
the Jinx Challenge.
♪♪ -J-J-Jinx,
J-J-J-Jinx Challenge ♪♪
-Now here, you put your hand
in this glove here.
-Okay. Got you. I got you.
-No problem. Here we go.
All right.
Here we go. So now look.
Here we are.
We're connected, right?
-We're connected. We are one.
-Yes, we are one.
There's no real reason that
we're wearing these gloves,
but it's fun for me.
It's very fashionable.
-Here's how it works.
What we do is we read
a category from this card
then count to three,
and then both say something in
that category at the same time.
-Okay.
-All right? When we say
the same thing, it is a jinx.
And let's have a goal.
Let's try to get two jinxes.
-Okay. We can do
better than that. Come on.
-Three jinxes?
-Yes. Let's do this.
Let's get this going.
-Really?
-Come on. We're connected.
-All right, here we go, pal.
Ready?
-Let's do it.
-Fashion magazines.
One, two, three.
-Vogue.
-Wow. Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ready?
-Okay.
-Body parts.
One, two, three.
-Legs.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Three, that's it, come on.
-Apps.
One, two, three.
-Instagram.
Oh, my God! Come on! Dude!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're fantastic.
Karlie Kloss, everybody.
We did not plan that.
The new season of
"Project Runway"
premieres Thursday
at 8:00 p.m. on Bravo.